know one of the things that we learned I
suspect everyone at this table Learned
was we learned about good
sportsmanship that when you lose you
have to be polite think about it in this
world today we're all winners okay no
one is being taught that um you know
that there's a winner and there's a
loser everybody is a winner everybody
gets a trophy that's what's going on in
schools today it's almost like then you
go to a game and there really are losers
and it's amazing that people who don't
need even have skin in the game they're
not even a part of the team they become
so outraged that they are willing to
kill somebody and we shouldn't have to
see stabbings and beatings that end up
in a homicide at a sporting event where
people supposedly as you say go to
forget their problems and to to join
other people and who knows whether it's
the pandemic or coid or the we are in a
world where there is a lack of Civility
there is a lack of consequence there is
a lack of law enforcement there is chaos
and Anarchy there is no there is no Law
and Order anymore and so you know when
you've got a Lakers guard who says he
won't take his kids to a basketball game
because he doesn't want his kids to hear
about what some of the fans are saying
about him you know that we are really on
the edge it's a Devolution of society